let's go 20 years from now
let's go 20 years from now it's 20 41.
okay 2041 um
and you know how for me when i look at
investments you'll sit down with a
client you'll say hey you know mr mrs
jones if you put this million dollars in
this account if it does 12 percent next
40 you know years
your money is going to double every six
years this millionaire is going to be
this much money but
eight percent is going to be this at six
percent is going to be this worst case
scenario
hits the fan we do four percent
your money's gonna double every 18 years
okay whatever great take compound
interest
but with power not money take today
with the way compound interest works
with power and influence
not money 20 years from now the
compounding
effort of china what does the world look
like 20 years from now if we don't stop
it what's going to happen is and
and i've already you know spoken to
people about this what will happen is
people will begin to educate their
children these are the things you can
say these are
things that you can't say um in china
you're talking about no in the u.s no in
the u.s in the u.s
in the u.s um because what will happen
is
you know just like i talk about roy
jones in my book you say the wrong thing
you'll get fired
from your job you won't get a you won't
get into the good school you won't get
into
uh you won't get the good job uh you
won't be able to get a loan
it though you'll basically be cut out of
the society no
so this is what you know so uh one of
the guys that was
um air attache for um uh people's
liberation army and you know talking to
his family
um the kid got here i think when he was
nine maybe and then he grew up in in u.s
schools
to the age of 15. so as at game time for
they know they have to go back to china
then the mom has to say to him
these are the things you cannot say when
we go back home
and you know and the reason i know this
because she's telling me
she's she's telling my wife i'm really
concerned because
he has grown up in the system he doesn't
understand
that he can't say these things it's not
okay
and it will be very bad for him and so
that's the world
that we are producing and and it's a
world that
you know as we get closer to china and
we start to
basically achieve that kind of control
of the narrative that narrative where
there's you can say just about anything
but if you get over here you're out
that's where we're headed and so you're
you it will be a world where you train
your
you train your kids not to say things
that will
damage your business damage your
reputation
make sure that they can't get into
school because you want your you want
your kids to succeed right
so the ultimately ultimately it's going
to be there's going
you know if it continues we're going to
have a single party system here in the
united states
and people will just like jackie chan
want to be in that party because if you
don't
not in that party you're not going to
have a job i mean it's the same it's a
classic
authoritarian system that this is how
you start to migrate to
just one party is in control and that's
what our founding fathers were terrified
of
and by the way that's why i quit the us
military because i i realized that
there's no way there's no way that the
military can do anything about this
it's really about data and information
and control of the narrative
and since we don't control our
information
we don't control our data since the
chinese communist party
has all of it and oh by the way the
chinese leadership basically told this
to trump they said hey
we own all the data we own your data we
own our data you guys are done
we're going our ai is going to be way
better than yours you can sell us
energy you can sell us food you can sell
us raw materials
if if you do what we say you don't do
what we say we're gonna cut you out
and so that's the belt and road
initiative
social will we be able to have the same
voice that we have will we be able to
say what we're saying today will
social media be the same 20 years from
now with us will this video stay up
that's the question what you're thinking
like you think it's going to get to that
point okay
but we're not there yet no so so the
great thing that
that i see happening and it's really
accelerated
in uh in in 2020 uh with the chronovirus
and now in 2021 with the build up of
china's military
and the breaking heads and the blood
will flow now people see
like oh i got it i got what's going on
my hope and it goes back to 2017 when
she became the ultimate leader
my hope is that he is so much like mao
that we will wake up and then we'll say
okay we've got to stop that we got to
come out of our slumber and we've got to
fix the system we've got to
we've got to protect our system we have
to rebuild it all the all the economic
you know the the the technological the
innovation the capital
we need to invest like i was just
talking to um the
the california employee retirement
system all the chief investment officers
and i said
do you calstrs do you invest in your own
community
no why where are you investing we're
investing in china
this is one of the biggest retirement
systems in the united states
they don't have a program to invest in
their own communities
this this is this is a funnel you might
remember pero's giant sucking sound
this is a the giant second town is all
the capital is flowing in through hong
kong into china
and not going in to build manufacturing
to build businesses i mean that's what's
going on you know you know it's crazy
all these policies when they said oh
we're going to come out with uh you know
we're going to give trillions of dollars
we should give people money
let's give people money all that we
should do that okay great so he gave the
money right and the guy
i don't know who the money manager was
guys a 10 billion guy says last year
was my biggest year of creating wealth
ever in my life right he says i'm so
rich right now i can't even tell you
this i don't even know what you do
he says what's crazy what people don't
realize all that money that they gave to
low and middle income families all flow
to the rich people
yep because the low and middle income
families don't have the right habits of
what to do with the money right it's
going to go up
what ended up also happening fast over
to june
of 2021 inflation is now up 5.4
yep 13-year high use car prices i don't
know if you saw that or not
the average car right now if you want to
brian by brand was 40 000
the average used car price went up 30
percent
in the last 12 months meaning some
people
bought a car that is worth more today
than 12 months ago when they bought it
because these micro you know these chip
shortages that are happening
and even ford just announced they're
going to produce 1.1 million fewer cars
it's going to cost for 2.5 billion
these are numbers that you're looking at
so many many times you sit and you look
at these policies like oh my gosh
these noble guys what they're doing how
amazing it is how they're looking out
for me i think people gradually and i
like the fact that you're saying because
when you say people are starting to
realize what these people are all about
all about these
how close he is to mao what american
president can get away with that
if an american president said can't if
anybody tries to do this to us we're
going to break their skulls
their heads what would happen if an
america you can't say something like
can't say it and it's never been said
like that and you can't go against the
chinese communist party we saw that
when when trump went against the party
he lost
period when trump went against the party
i mean his biggest sin was to go against
china
that's his biggest sanctions after
sanctions after tariffs after terrorism
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye